you get when you train AI to move fast
is you get things like somersaulting and
Silly Walks it's really common
so is twitching along the floor in a
heap so in my opinion you know what
should have been a whole lot weirder is
the Terminator robots hacking the matrix
is another thing that AI will do if you
give it a chance so if you train an AI
in a simulation it will learn how to do
things like hack into the simulations
math errors and harvest them for energy
or it'll figure out how to move faster
by glitching repeatedly into the floor
when you're working with AI is less like
working with another human and a lot
more like working with some kind of
weird force of nature and it's really
easy to accidentally give AI the wrong
problem to solve and often we don't
realize that until something has
actually gone wrong so here's an
experiment I did where I wanted the AI
to copy paint colors to invent new paint
colors given the list like the ones here
on the left and here's what the AI
actually came up with
so technically it did what I asked it to
so I thought I was asking it for like
nice paint color names what what I was
actually asking it to do was just
imitate the kinds of letter combinations
that it had seen in the original and I
didn't tell anything about what words
mean or that there are maybe some words
that it should avoid using in these
paint colors so it's entire world is the
data that I gave it like with the ice
cream flavors it doesn't know about
anything else so it is through the data
that we often accidentally tell AI to do
the wrong thing so this is a fish called
a tench and there was a group of
researchers who trained at AI to
identify this tension pictures but then
when they asked it what part of the
picture that I was actually using to
identify the fish here's what it
highlighted yes those are human fingers
why would it be looking for human
fingers if is trying to identify a fish
well it turns out that the ten choose a
trophy fish and so in a lot of the
pictures that the AI had seen of this
fish during training the fish looked
like this and it didn't know that the
fingers aren't part of the fish so you
see why it is so hard to design an AI
that actually can understand what it's
looking at and this is why designing the
image recognition in self-driving cars
is so hard and why so many self-driving
car failures are because the AI got
confused
I want to talk about an example from
2016 there was a fatal accident when
somebody was using Tesla's autopilot ai
but instead of using it on the highway
like was design for they used it on city
streets and what happened was a truck
drove out in front of the car and the
car failed to break now the AI
definitely was trained to recognize
trucks and pictures but what it looks
like happened is the a I was trained to
recognize trucks on highway driving
where you would expect to see trucks
from behind trucks on the side is not
supposed to happen on
highway and so when the AI saw this
truck
it looks like the AI recognized it as a
most likely to be a road sign and
therefore safe to drive underneath
here's an AI messed up from a different
field Amazon recently had to give up on
a resume sorting algorithm they were
working on when they discovered that the
algorithm had learned to discriminate
against women what happened is they had
trained it on example resumes of people
who they had hired in the past and from
these examples the AI learned to avoid
the resumes of people who had gone to
women's colleges or who had the word
women somewhere in their resume as in
women's soccer team or Society of Women
Engineers the AI didn't know that it
wasn't supposed to copy this particular
thing that it had seen the humans do and
technically it did what they asked it to
do they just accidentally asked it to do
the wrong thing and this happens all the
time with ai ai ai can be really
destructive and not know it
so the AIS that recommend new content in
Facebook in YouTube they're optimized to
increase the number of clicks and views
and unfortunately one way that they have
found of doing this is to recommend
content of conspiracy theories or
bigotry the AI is themselves don't have
any concept of what this content
actually is and they don't have any
concept of what the consequences might
be of recommending this content so when
we're working with AI it's up to us to
avoid problems and avoiding things going
wrong that may come down to the age-old
problem of communication where we as
humans have to learn how to communicate
with AI we have to learn what AI is
capable of doing and what it's not and
to understand that with its tiny little
worm brain AI doesn't really understand
what we're trying to ask it to do so in
other words we have to be prepared to
work with an AI that's not the super
competent all-knowing AI of science
fiction we have to be prepared to work
with an AI that's the one that we
actually have in the present day
and present-day AI is plenty weird
enough thank you
[Applause]
[Music]